[Music]
there are 178 loss a different shape on
the basis of sex women can work overtime
we have to get credit cards in our
husband's name
you think you can change the country you
should look to her generation they're
taking to the streets protests are
important but changing the culture means
nothing if the law doesn't change who
did you say your name was Ruth Bader
Ginsburg I want to be a lawyer I want to
represent clients in pursuit of justice
so they're gonna give you a corner
office I wasn't what they were looking
for one said women are too emotional to
be lawyers another told me a woman
graduating top of her class must be a
real ballbuster I worked hard I did
everything I was supposed to and I
excelled Martin Ginsberg will be signing
all of our checks someday a smart girl
with you married a star if the law
differentiates on the basis of sex then
how will women and men ever become equal
I don't read Tax Court cases read this
the law assumes a caregiver has to be a
woman
this is sex-based discrimination against
a man poor guy we need to take this case
it's not a case this is a declaration of
war
take a topple the whole damn system of
discrimination they think gender
equality is a civil right what's at
stake is the American family let's put
this idea to bed once and for all
you will lose and when you do you will
set the woman's moving back ten years
you don't get to tell me when to quit I
know this case disrupted our lives who
support if not for me
you've been ready for this your whole
life so go in there and let the judges
see through this Ginsburg I know we're
not asking you to change the country
that's already happened without any
court's permission
the word woman does not appear even once
in the US Constitution nor does the word
freedom your honor
[Music]